the biggest problem is what would come
next and even if somehow you could root
out Hamas again I'm not sure that's
possible because it's as much of an idea
and an ideology a movement in the mere
process of rooting them out in some ways
we create more converts but the larger
point is true and there's the problem
after 2005 a political vacuum would be
there I don't see anyone from the
outside ready and able to fill it the
Palestinian Authority can't even really
govern the West Bank how is it going to
govern Gaza the Arab world world really
wants no part of it the quote unquote
International Community lacks the
capacity and and the will and the
consensus to do it so again I just don't
see it as a serious short-term
alternative in the long run I'd love to
see Hamas marginalized but I think
that's going to require a whole
different political track and basically
show the Palestinians who are willing to
rule out force and live with Israel
compromised to reach some kind of a
coexistence that they will accomplish
much more by going down that path